the jurgen experience we were talking
today or yesterday rather with russell
peters about when was the last time you
saw a good comedy movie and can you make
a good comedy movie anymore or have they
have they made it so dangerous in terms
of like being canceled
that comedy movies are no longer
something you can do there's a movie
called i think it's called the
overnighters i might need to double
check on that the guy i think his name
is adam scott is that a
guy a comic actor and then um
who's the guy from rushmore who's great
jason schwartzman it's jason schwartzman
and adam scott i think it's called the
overnighters and it's [ __ ] hilarious
and how long ago would come out
i might need a check on that too maybe
five years ago yeah
that's about the cutoff it's a really
like low-budget
all-in-one place movie and it's like
hysterical i think i would wonder like
what is the cutoff in terms of like when
was the last time
a really good the overnight
yeah like when was the last time there
was like an edgy comedy
this one's not edgy but but it's good i
mean i guess there's some
it depends on what edgy means so many
different things to different people but
it's really [ __ ] funny you know what
i watched the other day
super bad yeah that's holy holy [ __ ]
you could never make that movie today
it's amazing how many things
just a few years later i mean the new
boer ad i thought was pretty funny
oh yeah yeah that but that's a weird one
right like he figured out a loophole
you're kind of doing parody and you're
doing this thing where you're freaking
people out like when she has her period
at the dance off right you know like
there's there's things that he could get
away with
in that it's a beautiful genre in that
regard right you could do stuff
in a kind of parody movie that you can't
do in a regular movie
yes but don't you find there's never
been maybe i'm wrong
but i feel like maybe i'm such a comedy
[ __ ] that i'm like
don't you feel like there's not never
been a ton of great comedy films
i feel like there's like a few a decade
um
it's hard to do a movie like i watched
step brother step brothers the other
night it's another movie you could never
do today
it's i think it's hard to do those like
some people just like judd apatow is
really good at making those kind of move
or was really good
i don't know if he's made one of those
kind of movies in a while but those like
really
ridiculous over-the-top movies but the
language and the subject matter and it's
like
the stuff that they talk about and say
to each other i just don't think you can
do that today or if you did do that
you would face a tremendous amount of
criticism
even though most people agree like you
try to watch stepbrother today
[ __ ] rock solid funny movie man
really funny right
i was crying like crying laughing
there's some
really funny moments in that movie were
you like i forgot how good this is
when he rubs his balls all over the
dude's drum set right like there's so
many of these moments where you're like
this is
so crazy but it feels like now people
are getting more
comedy from podcasts and stand up
than movies because it's making like i
watched the oscars and like they didn't
even make a joke there was like
zero jokes because everybody's so afraid
of the oscars this year i think there
was no host it was just like uh
we just bring people up i mean they
weren't even like attempting to do jokes
the only jokes were
the voice over lady that says like stay
tuned coming up brad pitt
i swear to god brad pitt's coming that
was like the only attempt at
humor it was like really well they
when kevin hart didn't do it because
they wanted him to apologize for
jokes that were homophobic from many
years ago
um and he said look i'm not going to do
this i've already apologized for those
jokes
i evolved i grew i'm not the same person
anymore and that's fine
i don't need to do it you know and then
they didn't have a host that year i
believe
and i think that's it i don't think
they've had a host since then
right right i don't know you might be
right about that i know the one year
they had two it was james franco and
anne hathaway
hosted it okay because they did they
went non-comics
but it does feel like right now it's
like
rude to even try to be funny on that
high
level yeah it's very bizarre i was
listening to a podcast the other day
that i love
that's sort of like a mental health
podcast and this lady was telling the
host he was like a straight
white guy he was like i'm learning about
privilege and he was saying even my
self-defecating humor is a little bit
offensive because
it's my privilege to do self-deprecating
humor because as a straight white male
people
assume i'm joking but other people
couldn't make such
jokes because of whatever history and
they were literally discussing
earnestly how straight white men
shouldn't really try to be funny it was
that guy castrato
it felt a little castratory yeah i mean
it was just a really
bizarre conversation you can never be
woke enough that's the problem it keeps
going
it keeps going further and further and
further down the line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no i
know i know it really will get there
it's that crazy you know we just got to
be nice to each other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes
their thing their thing is calling
people out for their privilege calling
people
out for their position you know it's so
[ __ ] crazy times yeah most definitely
but i do feel like
there's more there's it feels like i
hear more people
sort of speaking out against that kind
of stuff than i hear
from people saying that's a good idea
like i think there's way more people
that are like what that's insane well
especially in our circles
true yeah maybe i'm in a bubble i don't
know yeah i mean we're definitely in a
comedy bubble i mean this is
what we do we talk [ __ ] right you know
when you talk [ __ ] and you see something
stupid like that like as a straight
white man i shouldn't be
self-deprecating like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah i mean
i'm in a lot of trouble if we can't do
that but yeah we're humans
if you're a human being you should be
able to express yourself you shouldn't
have to take into account
all the other people that are either not
heard or not expressing themselves
currently
or not in the same you know whatever
category is you like come
on man we can't do that because that's
what you're doing is you're
you're forcing yourself to think
double and triple about every single
[ __ ] thing you say and whether or not
you have the right to say it whether or
not you have the right to express
yourself
yeah and then nobody's having fun that
doesn't seem like a fun way to live at
all
it's a terrible way to live catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience